[Music]  [Applause]  Fraser  [Applause]  Cantor's till World War  [Applause]  4:48 change  lankford this is a corner three we're  out of April  chuckles taking a seat again how we got  a whistle  [Applause]  [Music]  [Laughter]  if in the game  why against Victor 18 reboot maker  it makes mentor look like a little kid  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  with the black in the fire  [Applause]  that was a guess  okay well I'm sure we'll take a look at  you  there's lactose for taco protector taco  you wanna make  [Applause]  [Music]  zipping on this island sighs taco making  a move back the other way comes back  with the hook gets the charge that's the  court  [Applause]  crashing flora  with it  probably not a good idea  [Applause]